when european sailors reached the new
world they soon came across the native
peoples there
and these people had no idea of the
europe existing let alone any idea of
how to speak to a person from there
but as you'll know contact was made and
in many cases complicated arrangements
were negotiated between europeans and
natives
but given that there were no
interpreters when europeans first
arrived this raises a question
how did they communicate how do european
explorers talk to natives
so generally speaking when a culture
makes contact with another there's
normally people along the way who can be
used as interpreters
when colonized in africa europeans would
often bring arabic speaking peoples with
them to translate
this was because sea trade had linked
north africa with the south for
centuries and in the larger kingdoms
there would be people at ports who could
speak arabic
however with the atlantic ocean and
those living on the other side of it
there was none of that
so how did say christopher columbus
communicate with the natives he met on
hispaniola when he arrived there in
1492.
well for this they used the only correct
form of communication
they used signs now this was mostly sign
language like pointing to things and
saying its name or acting something out
and then saying the word for it but they
would also make crew drawings as things
became more complicated
this covered most of the basics like
food shelter jesus golden boats but any
complicated discussions would require a
full translator
and since it would be pretty difficult
to ask a native using a sign if they'd
like to get on the ship and head back to
spain over an ocean for an immersive
crash course in spanish so you can act
as a translator in the future for us
they settled for another option kidnap
unfortunately for columbus and the
natives he taken they didn't survive
very long because disease
so how did this change long term well
after this the spanish would capture
natives and they'd keep them in the
region to learn the language so there
was less dying
another way was that some spanish ships
became shipwrecked and those who
survived would be taken as slaves by the
natives and would soon learn their
languages and could act as interpreters
on behalf of the native american rulers
and once spaniards and natives knew one
or two languages the rest was fairly
simple
since it simply meant stringing
translators together to communicate
and it was after this short period that
communication just became the same as it
was
anywhere else in the world i hope you
enjoyed this episode and thank you for
watching with a special thanks to my
patrons
james bissonette mr wolf kelly
moneymaker sky chappelle rob d martin
captain cydog marvin cassal moe aaron
the white adam stalter jordan longley
boogery wiggly gustav swan jerry lamdin
rasheed ali gareth turner
maggie patzkowski coppertone winston k
wood spinning three plates corso wolff
marcus asner spencer lightfoot matthew
shipley the mug whopper alex schwinn
lil brep and tc robert wetzel anthony
beckett charles the first
and scottish trekkie